everyone and welcome to tonight's very
timely conversation entitled rethinking
regeneration my name is Chris lopkin and
I have the pleasure and the privilege of
being the leader of the Strategic
foresight Hub at the Office of the
President in each H Zurich and most
importantly for tonight I get to be your
host for the
conversation we are again here in this
Splendid location of the museum forur
kunda in Berlin the building opened 1889
a very impressive year for architecture
all over the world was built on a site
of Iron Works is why the beautiful
stairways are so beautiful Goose eyes
and their cast iron it was bombed during
World War II and as you can see today it
is a fabulous manifestation of
regeneration it is a living place a
place where life has been brought in
again the Berlin science week is a forum
for scientists and science-driven
organizations to engage with the public
share insights on current topics discuss
Grand challenges and to Envision the
future together we the E Zurich are very
proud to have been a part of the Berlin
science week since it's inaugural
Edition in
2017 it's hard to believe it's gone by
so quickly
actually and the door is open and I can
hear it that's good our dialogue this
evening is part of eth zurich's
rethinking living
campaign many of us have the feeling
that we're confronting massive changes
to just about every aspect of Our Lives
climate change biodiversity loss
democracy being disputed Global pandemic
makes Wars and technological
disruptions present clear and present
danger for all of us and but more
importantly they also present us an
opportunity to focus on finding
solutions to these Grand challenges to
embrace much deeper meaning to our
existence perhaps and to ReDiscover
overlooked aspects of Our
Lives rethinking living invites us to
touch the core meaning of our Humanity
our role in the systems of the world
around us and to Foster hopefully a more
clear and deeper sense of
purpose so let's get
started we have three amazing guests
with us tonight and it is truly an honor
to be up here with them all very
passionate and have a very clear purpose
to what they're doing in in with their
lives all of them first we have next to
me Ralph Mueller he's a professor at eth
Zurich and a global leader in
biomechanics he is pioneered scientific
advancements in bioimaging and
mechano
mechanobiology did I get that right yeah
all right great good and significantly
impacting tissue regeneration research
and co-founding Enterprises focused on
Innovative medical technology so let's
welcome Ralph give me a hand here we go
all
right next we have next to him Josephine
graph Josephine is the co-ceo and one of
our four female co-founders of R reefs
reefs not quite sure how we say it
you're going to correct me later a Swiss
startup that focuses on Coral Reef
regeneration with her background in
business and political science she is
passionate about advancing climate
action and sustain aable development
welcome
Joseph and
finally a man I would call our local
hero here in here at pick an
internationally recognized scientist
Swedish scientist on global
sustainability issues and director of
the pot Stam Institute for climate
impact research or pick where he for
example in his career in the past 20
years has led many developments
especially around the planetary boundary
framework and the the new planetary
frame new planetary boundary framework
which you're going to tell us a little
bit more about um an advocate an
extremely strong advocate for
Sustainable Solutions in the current ERA
of Rapid Global
change welcome
Yan so our time together with here
present today and also online is going
to be about 75 minutes each of our
panelists are going to start off by a
short introduction to their work can't
wait to see it and then we're going to
have a discussion here on the up on the
desk and then you our audience are going
to be asked or given the opportunity or
asked to ask questions of these three
individuals and I can tell you it's not
often that we'd have these three to ask
questions of in such an easy manner so
periodically I'll ask you do you have a
question and if you do have a question
just raise your hand I'm going to
count one or two aren't isn't going to
do it you have to have three or four
including online so we have three or
four or five then we're going to start
asking questions so Johan we're going to
start with you if we can and planetary
boundary
framework there's one and now there's a
new one yep there's an update yeah great
no good evening everyone and before
coming to the assessment which you have
here on the wall I think it's very
special to discuss regeneration at the
narur Museum here in Berlin because we
know now scientific basically that our
home planet Earth can only exist in
three stable equilibrium states that all
are self-regulated through regenerative
capacities and one extreme is the
snowball Earth let's simply exclude that
one the last time we had a snowball
Earth was over 100 million years ago the
second state is this extraordinary limit
cycle that we've had over the past 1
million years when we have 100,000 years
of Ice Age separated by short periods of
warm interglacials the equilibrium
states which the last one the Hol scene
which is the one that had enabled has
enabled civilizations to develop as we
know them the very reference point for a
desired planet and then we had a third
state and this third state is the one
that is at risk of today becoming a
self-propelling journey into the future
and that is the hot house Earth State
and the last time we have had in Hot
House Earth state is roughly 50 million
years ago when the guys downstairs
roamed on planet Earth this was the
dinosaurs this was the tropical Planet
this is a planet that moves away towards
a point where we lose all the Ice Age
all the ice sheets on planet Earth and
we have a a warm Planet which is four
five degrees warmer than today why does
it end up in that state well it's not
because of just solar radiated forcing
it's regenerative capacities it's
feedback dynamics that self-propel
itself into this warm State the biggest
fear we have today is that we will shift
the planet due to our human induced
unsustainable undermining of
regenerative capacity from the Hol scene
towards a trajectory that would Drift
Away un unstoppably towards a hot house
Earth State I would argue that this is
like the number one biggest challenge we
have as Humanity that's why we developed
the planetary boundary framework because
what this does is to ask two questions
one scientific question is what are the
big biophysical systems that regulates
the regenerative capacity of the planet
and once we have identified those
processes and we've identified nine we
ask ourselves the question can we
quantify safe boundaries that gives us a
safe operating space seen here in green
that gives us a high likelihood of
keeping the planet in a desired
equilibrium state which has enabled
human development as we know it the Hol
scene State push ourselves outside of
these safe boundaries and we have a high
likelihood of triggering unregenerated
actually self-amplifying feedbacks that
can push the planet in a direction where
we lose life support systems and
ultimately have existential potentially
completely unmanageable disaster future
for Humanity now this was first
published in 2009 as a challenge for the
scientific ific Community it came about
as a result of 30 years of extraordinary
scientific advancement on resilience
science Tipping Point science and the
unequivocal evidence that we've entered
a whole new geological Epoch the
anthropos scene meaning that the
pressures on planet Earth has made us
humans not the dominating force of
change on planet Earth so there was a
lot of evidence into this we've
identified the nine boundaries and you
have the nine here and this is um today
15 years later uh confirmed through over
2,000 peer viwed scientific papers that
have come out and critically assessed
the framework that if we can get it
right on these nine I would today argue
that we have very strong scientific
support that then we have a good chance
of having you know manageable living
conditions on Earth for all generations
into the future but the big breakthrough
is that we've been able to quantify for
the first time safe boundaries for all
the nine boundaries in 2015 in the last
last update we could only do six now
what you see here is for the first time
all the nine and this is published in
science advances for just two months ago
the dramatic message to humanity which
is shown on this screen is that six of
the nine boundaries are outside of the
safe space it's not only climate it's
also what I call the biosphere
boundaries of biodiversity loss you see
that in the upper left hand corner there
existential risks facing the fact that
we're in the six mass extinction of
species and they were losing functional
diversity like carbon sequestration
capacity moisture feedback all forms of
of ecosystem provision of services to
humanity land system change overuse of
freshh water and overloading of reactive
nitrogen and phosphorus particularly
through overuse of
fertilizers this is very very worrying
because what this means that even if you
focus only on trying to solve the
climate crisis
we are in trouble because by
transgressing by breaching the biosphere
boundaries planet Earth is losing its
regenerative capacity so we are in the
like in the worst of situations we have
this massive human caused energy
imbalance by burning fossil
fuels and when you pose that tremendous
stress on a system of course you want to
have a strong system but unfortunately
we are by breaching all the nature
boundaries losing the capacity the
resilience of the system to buffer that
stress caused by climate so we have a
weak Planet when we need a stronger
Planet more than ever that's not a good
combination but that's unfortunate where
we are today that's why we talk today of
a planetary emergency because we're
losing regenerative capacity on planet
Earth we have to very very quickly
transform oursel back into this safe
space let me just close Chris by saying
that you know we're very close to the
cop 28 CL climate negotiations in Dubai
we will come to Dubai saying this is the
last chance we have of now starting to
seriously bend the curve of emissions to
start you know phasing out coal oil and
gas we need to really embark on the
mitigation pathway but let me just
reinforce with you that we have now a
number of scientific papers that shows
that even that will not take us to a
manageable 1.5 degre Celsius limit which
is what science tells us is the limit
that will keep us away from danger and
the danger is shown on the mapping of
tipping points so we have this
assessment today of the 16 big tipping
points systems that not only regulates
the stability climate system but they
have multiple stable States push them
too far and they will shift from one
state the state we need to another state
where they will self- amplify warming
more methane from Thor and permafrost
losing all the core Reef systems that
we'll hear much more about right now the
big biomes like this uh rainforest
systems that are carbon sinks now what
you see here is for the first time in
the dark
colors the estimate of at what
temperatures are we at risk of Crossing
tipping points where these systems will
very likely tip over from the state
protecting us to states where they
amplify warming the dark red ones are
those that are likely to cross the
Tipping points already at 1.5° C and
just look at the map the GRE ice sheet
the West Antarctic ice sheet all the
tropical core Reef systems and the loss
of the barren seais so this is a
scientific warning that the boundaries
are real and that we have to truly
recognize the need for the regenerative
capacity of the entire planet to have
any chance even if we only focus in on
climate and that is why this whole
discussion is so Central and looking at
the dinosaurs and what happened to that
Civilization on planet Earth we don't
want that to be the end for our human
civilization on Earth and for that we
need to truly invest on in our
regenerative capacity across all scales
and we'll hear much more of that here
tonight that's great thank you thank you
very much for the very sobering
introduction and it's very important for
us to remember that dinosaurs were on
our planet for quite a long time I think
it was about 165 million years if I'm
yeah we've just been around for 250,000
exactly so we need to get we need to do
some schooling here and I think it
sounds like what you're indicating is we
need some lessons and this word learning
and let's move over to the reefs so he
mentioned one of the one of the systems
is the low latitude cor reefs and
Josephine this is your passion sure so
tell us about what you're
doing I'm part of reefs we are an eth
spin-off from Basin Zer and we are
rebuilding coral reefs with 3D printed
uh modular clay re uh clay modules and
this is one of them so you can think a
bit like it's like Lego you can staple
them underwater and create these
underwater reefs and um and actually
this is our pilot Reef which we built
two years ago in the Caribbean which is
now H this photo was taken two years ago
uh no one year ago after one year
monitoring and you can see how the
corals are growing and baby corals are
settling so our reefs is specifically
designed to attract baby corals to
settle at the surface and to grow and so
to go back to the regenerative
capacity um also Co reefs have we think
or we let nature take back so we bring
these structures underw but then it's
nature to grow here and from genetic um
diversity these baby corals settle here
and grow and we can also see that after
8 months we saw the first baby corals on
our reef and this is despite in the
Caribbean also there are many stressors
like local Factor such as over fishing
pollution there's a big problem with
algae growing um but also of course
climate change and overheating and coral
bleaching I don't know if you know that
corals become white if it's too hot and
this is currently happening actually in
the Caribbean so in Florida P has lost
more than approximately 90% of their
corals just now and now we see the heat
wave also coming to our pilot Reef um on
the island of San andras in Colombia and
so we can see firsthand what climate
change does also to to corals and re but
still we see Baby Coral settling despite
um these stresses and I think that also
shows us and I have actually another
photo of a baby Coral so we monitor them
um every half year and we still see
these baby called settlings so now we
have on every nearly on every module of
our of our Reef we have one Baby Coral
and this is two to three times higher
than on the natural reefs so we
monitoring this closely and and yeah
that's really fantastic so and and your
goal with this is to bring this to not
just the Caribbean but to all other
parts of the world as well is there a
specific latitude that works with your
system better than others or is it the
the tropics were good where the where
cories exist yes exactly and we started
with the Caribbean because we got the
permit there as well so we always need
permits we need negotiations with
governments to install these so it was
more practic practical point of view to
to go there but now we're starting in
the Philippines to do a larger
regeneration project so next year but
let me why did you start
this what are you a diver or do you just
you like little you like little reefs or
why was this where did this come from I
have to say it was not my idea two
co-founders so we have four co-founders
as you said we all women we all very
passionate about climate action and our
oceans and or and Marie who are not here
today they met at eth mhm and um R is a
marine biologist and Marine artist and
they both worked on um underwater
structures or Marie created art which um
which she did also underwater to kind of
uh raise awareness about the topic of
coral reefs and or um did yeah did her
PhD on Surface structures that uh can
attract corals and they met at eth and I
think that's also an interesting part of
re that we kind of combine Arts so we
still see that Arts is a useful mean for
us to kind of educate especially in
Switzerland and Germany where where
reefs are not so close um and also to
have you fly to them you can fly to them
and then you can fly to them yeah
shouldn't fly to them or you can
shouldn't fly too much yeah I know
exactly I was being a bit factious with
that one that was but I think the
combination of science and art um also
sets us apart good from other Solutions
but you mentioned that's thank you for
that it's really fantastic and you
mentioned this sort of trying to regrow
and this is where you're looking at
helping corals recol recolonize and
regrow repopulate so they can continue
to to sequester carbon as one of the
things that they can do right yeah and
Ralph you're all about regrowing I get
right we need to if you can pass down
the thing this is this is what you
have made your name in and
regrowing well yeah and regeneration is
you know in a biological and medical
sense and of course the structures that
we have are much smaller and I I just
want to show for example if you take a a
bone and you do an osteotomy so taking a
piece out of the bone um you can see how
the bone regrows right in between those
two parts this is in a living
system but um there's constraints in
sometimes in how this can regrow so we
have also uh lose some of the
regenerative uh capacities uh if we do
that uh while Aging for example and and
one of the ways that we can overcome
that is we use a loading for example
right so you look at the left side you
can see that in the first few weeks we
have the same same behavior between the
two systems but then we start putting
extra mechanical forces vibrational
forces on the left system and then you
can see how this regenerates much better
so um for for me it's an important part
I'm engineer by training and uh you know
of course we can learn from nature right
nature does know how to regenerate but
if you have a certain age somehow then
we fail to do that for example or if
certain disease you might fail to do
that and how can we engineer those
systems that we can overcome some of
these hurdles and I find it fascinating
and how to look at these capacities that
you have in such you know let's say
small systems on a cell scale um you
know resolutions that you're talking
here is a few hundred micr or something
like that um so um to to look also at at
the world right so we heard about what
are the driving factors and how can we
maybe stop uh that but how can we maybe
engineer some of these things to help
nature um help us to overcome some of
these problems and I think this is where
we can learn from medicine and it's and
we have a term that has been around for
a long time regenerative medicine and
where we help basically the systems with
cell engineering or you know outside
stimulus and to to make a better system
in the end so I think this is maybe we
can do that and and one reasons why I
think you brought me here is is is
wonderful in these uh bones I mean they
they first of all they're very dynamic
in how they remodel over time and second
is that they do that scarless right so
you take a piece out and that's very
important and I'll come back to that
later when you do regeneration you
cannot have regeneration without taking
something away you cannot regenerate
something that is in place it's
impossible you need to take something
away first and then you can regenerate
get new functions in there and in the
end bone does it scarless there is not a
scar that you can see we know all skin
we have maybe our little scars every now
and then somewhere right that stay for
Lifetime bone doesn't do that bones
heels scullers and I think that's
something we could find out how this is
done and so we can use this also for
other applications and I think that's
something to study and this
interdisciplinary parts are then very
important to work together that's really
fasinating so when you say scarless this
is I'm thinking our systems when you're
looking with your reefs they're I mean
they're scarred or the losses we've seen
I mean what is it what kind of a thought
does that trigger in the two of you in
one of you who who wants to Johan when
you think of when you hear this we have
to have loss in order of
regeneration what do you think yeah well
I mean one one thing it it reminds us
which I think is really one of the few
lights in the tunnel we have is that
nature has this remarkable capacity to
bounce back and even under tremendous
pressures like the where the coral reefs
are suffering on you know across the
entire planet but look at any species
any fish species plants ecosystems they
have this this remarkable capacity as
long as you don't push them really too
far so the scar cannot go too deep they
have a possibility once you release the
pressure to to come back in a in a quite
remarkable way so I think um that that's
proof of um of the life force or
regenerative capacity so so I think it's
but it's not we don't have evidence that
that that scars would would um sort to
say be beneficial but it just shows that
uh we have a responsibility to to reduce
educe pressure once we've caused the
scar it's interesting because I think of
your the the system which you've
demonstrated the planetary boundaries we
showing one whereas complete loss versus
damage and I'm just curious when you in
your research for both of you damage
versus complete loss you say you remove
a piece of bone what if if you damage it
does that does that it's um it's similar
in that sense right so if you destroy
life in that part so damage and they get
necrotic or something like that of
course it will never heal you have to
take it away think about the tumor as
well right that destroys maybe bone
first you have to take away the tumor
well then you end up with maybe a a
defect that is too big right and so this
will never heal MH not heal with scar or
no scar will never heal what you do you
put something inside and I think the
reef is exactly the same there will be
no Reef if we don't put a printed
structure there that allows for these to
settle again so basically if it's
necrotic you have to take it out it's
like a cancer and then you can put
something in maybe you have to put
something in you cannot just wait for
that to be you know destroyed by Nature
it will take way too long so you have to
go in there and do it take it out and
put something new so that's I think
that's kind of an interesting comparison
to maybe climate change and a tumor um
in the sense that as I said I think we
really believe in Nature's capacity to
regenerate and that's why we also put
this the foundation in the water to for
corals then to settle and grow but at
the same time as you said if we don't do
anything now because the regenerative
capacity is not there anymore is not
functioning anymore because the climate
change is accelerating so fast for
corals and it's becoming too hot we will
lose cor reefs very soon as as was
indicated by 2050 it's very likely that
we have lost more than 95% of our cies
if we stay at the current emission path
so it's true you have to kind of
proactively regenerate to kind of keep
we always say we we buy corals a bit
more time to um boost their resilience
but of course it's not it's not the
solution for climate change it's one
maybe one of the solutions which you can
combine sure it's a step it's a little
piece I think it's quite intriguing said
so go I'm sorry did you want no I think
it's really quite intriguing because you
said this this this I I kind of come
back to this idea of loss total loss and
you something you have to put something
back right and if we step over some of
these boundaries where what does it mean
to put something back you've got you
found a helper for the reef systems but
when we're looking at some other some of
these other systems which are in their
red are do we know those pathways are
those Pathways clear of say the the
coral reef pieces or are we
still um search SE in for that yeah and
I would I think that's a really
important question Chris because I mean
now we've talked in quite positive
optimistic terms that even if you even
if you have quite deep scars in the
biosphere there's this remarkable
resilience and capacity to re regenerate
but we also know that if you push
systems too far it can be impossible to
turn back and particularly when it comes
to living systems if if you push um
Extinction of species you cannot
regenerate a lost species it's gone
forever we are at risk actually of of
completely losing big coral reef Marine
systems are at risk of of complete
collapse and then you you won't be able
to regenerate them I mean it's not at
scale at least at least we don't have
any any proof of that so we have to be
you
know the the good news is that we don't
have evidence that we have yet cross
those absolute finite lines even if
we're in the dark red of transgressing
boundaries it's a warning that the
system is under so high stress that it's
losing it its capacity to regenerative
or to to to step step back but but we
have to turn back before we cross those
red really dark red lines when the
system can no longer come back and and
we have examples of dead zones in some
of the ocean systems desertification
areas I mean we have U Mass loss of
species in in in some ecosystems in the
world just look at the aen red list for
example so so we know that there are
absolute lines in the sand as well sure
yeah but this is interesting with your
research come back off is I the analogy
is quite intriguing to
me what other I'm thinking of other
biomechanics other and there are other
systems because within within your
larger domain there are other species
who can regenerate there's living tissue
which can regenerate our liver can
regenerate I wish my brain could
regenerate generate on Sunday morning
but that doesn't do that but you know
but are there any other lessons insights
that you could share with us from what
your studies and your colleagues with
that specific Theory yeah I mean of
course um you know so so I'm talking
about here A system that if you don't
make a
huge defect let's say it's not a scar
you it will heal scarless but make a
huge defect if it's not huge it just do
does it naturally but what we want to
learn from for example are you know
experiments that people do with
salamanders or nudes right when you can
basically cut off a limb and it's fully
restored right I'm not saying that
there's no pain in that I'm just saying
that this can happen and this is not
possible say in in in uh in humans and I
think we should you know like I'm
totally with you that we have to be
careful not to go that route and not
trust that we can regenerate that but we
should do more research right that looks
at how can we help those systems to
regenerate because it just not having to
always count only on nature right we we
infringed it on nature maybe we can help
nature as well to do better than it was
was designed for and I think that's
something that is at least of interest
for me and we are constantly studying
those systems to find out on a molecular
level you know why is a nude able to do
that and you know beautifully and and we
are not and and this is to do of course
also with the environment that they are
right so I think that's a very important
part so you have to give the boundary
conditions such that the mechanics are
correct for example and otherwise it
cannot so the physics around it right
needs to be correct the chemistry around
it needs to be correct and we can help
sometimes those systems to actually do
that right so this one important thing
and I think another thing that is very
important I feel like it's you know um
in in humans or or other species animals
we have generational um
regeneration right so that's also why
you call it regeneration because you
have a generation of people My
Generation a lot of people I see here
different generation and we rejuvenate
through that right n nature we we
haven't found that so much right so it
looks like it's a long 200 million years
or something like that but could we also
make help the system by faster uh
regeneration really a new generation of
nature that will take over and be faster
than the one and heal you know in that
sense because we really Bank on that the
young people you know they are fitter
you know and it will go the same way
they will get older and then there's no
life anymore but we regenerate right and
so how does nature do that in a climate
sense maybe or maybe somebody knows but
I I don't know right or corals as well
of course I don't know what their
lifetime is and maybe just to say with
corals it's the same as with salamanders
if you cut them they grow together again
and regrow so they're also very
resilient and they Al also existed since
I think the dinosaur age so they much
more resilient than humans maybe so
let's see but just maybe on this topic
um because we also think for example
technology could be a way right to kind
of help nature to regenerate but it's
not the solution right what we see also
we use 3D printing technology to kind of
as a means to create the shapes we want
and to also create the surface structure
which is our hypothesis really works for
baby corals to settle and grow um but of
course also for coral reefs there are so
many success factors also in our reefs
if they if cors grow there from local
factors as I mentioned over fishing to
um govern governments protecting the
reefs to climate change and I think so
it's not just technology right which
like where we can innovate our weight
way out of climate change or of the
biodiversity loss um which is like the
biggest topic for for Cores as 25% of
marine animals depend on cores and it's
one of the Tipping points and we don't
know what happens will if cores are lost
because it's Chain Reaction no one
really knows like if the whole Marine
ecosystem collapses it's one of those
experiments we don't really want to try
to yeah so it's kind of a balance right
technology or a helping nature but also
really regarding nature as kind of a
technology which has a capacity which
has greater capacity to regenerate than
uh than Technologies we have at the
moment yeah I want just to follow up on
on Ralph's really important point on on
re generations and thinking about
Generations one of the things that I
find and and I think we have to be a bit
self-critical as scientists as well that
that we've completely failed to
communicate which is that I would argue
that it doesn't care so much if if you
are skeptic or not with regards to
whether fossil fuel burning is cing
causing warming the the key issue is to
recognize that the pace of change right
now on planet Earth is completely
unprecedented irrespective of who's
causing it it's it's way way beyond the
regenerative capacity of all living
species on planet Earth so because if
you look at the last 1 million years
we've passed through eight long ice ages
and short interglacials and the
temperatures during that period have
been you know the warmest below 2° C of
warming and the coldest minus 4 you're a
deep Ice Age I call this the corridor of
Life Below two the warmest minus four is
an ice age you actually can take that
back even 3 million years so the whole
query has never been outside of this
very narrow range when you look at the P
fastest uh pace of change you roughly
increase one temperature in Thousand
Years that's a that's a good rule of
thumb you you leave an Ice Age it takes
about 5,000 years from -4 to plus2 it's
like 1 Dee per thousand years that
that's that's what our Evolution can
cope with now we've increased
temperature on Earth with one degree in
100 years so we we're going 10 to
actually 100 times faster than anything
we know in the geological history of
planet Earth it's not surprising that
species are are stressed and and that we
see more more more signs that we're kind
of Crossing the the limits of adaptation
and I think this this in itself you know
lends itself to just well a lot of
humbleness in terms of what's happening
on planet Earth but I think that should
be sufficient to act very very
resolutely on on trying to you know
build a more resilient future that you
know you just look at what's happening
and it's kind of going so fast and just
look at 2023 you know all the numbers
are completely off the charts yeah if
you look at uh social media and science
exchange on LinkedIn it's just
extraordinary oceanographers are just
you know expressing themselves in ways
that I've never experienced before
because surface temperatures are like
not not one standard deviation outside
of what's been experienced on the 50
years it's two three times and we cannot
even explain it you know what's
happening so this is uh this has to be
recognized the pace of change is
extraordinary it's kind of beyond the
regen the the generative capacity over
Generations yeah I think that's a really
important point to to remind us as we do
these actions and think about what we're
doing is that pace of change there's the
absolute reality that we need to focus
on you know and I think because it's
both a global and a local issue and I'm
going to be coming to you guys for some
questions very soon any you having a
question yet or you're just
going no
questions okay cool I'll keep going so
this is both a global and a local issue
because your reefs are extremely local
you're putting your heart down bone and
my bone this is about you know in global
so for you as individuals um how do you
see this Meandering between the global
and the local the the mindsets of that
we need to be holding as we're
rethinking this this
topic constantly speeding up and
changing how do you how do you negotiate
this who wants to who wants to head
first I can start maybe sure yeah I
think for us maybe it's also important
to say we always build our reefs with
local Partners cool yeah so we always
engage the local community because of
course and these are local communities
in the tropics and often also least
developed countries or developing
countries so that not have the means to
restore core reefs often times and I
think this is really important to bring
local communities also in also to
protect our reefs to to have a to have
sustainability of our projects over time
um and to have the Buy in as well to
have also this or to highlight the
social impact socio economic impact of
reef as well because it's not only
biodiversity and nature but it's also if
a re is lost it's also direct
consequences for people who live there
but also I mean in broader sense if they
all are lost also for us directly here
yeah um and this was fed for example
through Coastal erosion as well because
they break waves very efficiently but
then also to loss of Fisheries um loss
of income from tourism and so on so I
think this local perspective is very
important for us and then also to have
the Buy in from governments um yeah but
you also have the global scale all the
times with climate change and like these
bigger issues which you have to address
at the same time great thanks Johan you
look like you were going to chime in
yeah I may say something that that may
come across a bit as a surprise or or or
not being so so conventional in thinking
which is that to be honest Chris I think
your question is wrong uh I I don't
think it it really applies anymore and
what do I mean by that I mean that you
know the planet is not a big thing
anymore it's a very very small unit and
the reason for this is the world has
become so big so we today live in a very
big world on a very small planet and and
of course the planet has always been
small I mean the atmosphere is 20 km so
all life is in this very very limited
film that on a bicycle it takes you half
an hour and you're kind of Beyond it but
but you know up until the mid 1950s we
were still a relatively small world on a
big planet you know there was redundant
colar reefs and fish and ocean and
atmosphere to pollute and trees to cut
and we could expand agriculture we could
exploit and have these linear production
systems consuming and producing waste
and it didn't cause planetary damage but
since the 1990s we can today say we
filled up the whole system it's
completely saturated on all every square
meter is saturated so today there is no
such thing as as a as a big planetary
scale out there every Community every
business every city every individual has
to recognize that we are completely
intertwined in this very fragile small
system planet Earth and I think that's
one of the I I only talk about
scientific failures tonight our
inability to communicate I think one
additional failure is that we haven't
made it clear that we have to become
every one of us stewards of of this
little precious Planet so I think it's
it's more the question of how do we
integrate scales and you know every
planetary boundary actually translates
to a budget just like we've understood
that the climate boundary of the Paris
agreement translates to a carbon budget
it translates to a trajectory that every
country every business needs to follow
well I can tell you it's the same thing
for fresh water for nitrogen for
phosphorus for land for biodiversity so
so it's not difficult to see the chain
from from that Global level to the local
level and and I think we need to Simply
reconfigure ourselves to recognize that
if I'm in Germany and I want to have a
good modern welfare state in Germany I
want to have good jobs and a good life
for my kids I better connect to the
planet I I better be equally concerned
about the green and ice sheet the Amazon
rainforest and the core Reef systems
because they are completely determining
the outcome also for Germany because
it's all interconnected you cannot
disconnect from an ecosystem on the
other side of the planet anymore because
they're all all kind of impacting each
other so I think
today it's it's like it's just one scale
it's all
together it's
us I want to go with that Johan I really
do and I think there's so many billions
of people who have a hard time just even
getting a handle on where they exist for
sure right and trying to think trying to
negotiate
between what you've just described which
I also subscribe to but the reality of
so many people just scrabbling for that
existence and how how to say to them oh
you've got to worry about the whole
world and like like actually try to get
some fish to feed my family and this is
this interesting dilemma I think which
we grapple with you know it's just it so
I hear you and no no I agree and and and
as we know populism and nationalism and
egoism and distrust is rather pushing Us
in the other direction at the towards
more and more kind of shutting Us in and
building walls I agree yeah it's a
challenge very much so okay I want to
turn to the questions again I saw
there's there a couple questions online
I understand anyone else in the room
have one we have one up front anyone
else everyone okay good not just
consumption this is also interaction
tonight there we go so Alexandra from
tonight from the from our online
audience let here what what do you have
read it out to us the question is what
needs to be done to convince decision
makers that the scientific framework
conditions are in place and it is time
to adapt and implement the framework
conditions to our legal economic and
social system
what would you say to
that Johan just start well not sure I
can answer sure can I think there are
two two
stories both equally important and and
of course by now you you know my first
story which will that will be that we
have to stay with the facts and we have
to communicate that we are approaching
unmanageable risks and that we may cross
these these very important boundaries
Beyond which there is no regenerative
capacity which would be very very big
risks I think that's important and I
think we should continue to to
communicate that but equally important
is the story that we haven't talked so
much about today which is that we have
so much evidence today that
sustainability and resilience and
regenerative Pathways is actually the
only pathway that can take us towards
you know the sustainable development
goals or whatever you want to call a
modern
healthy competitive attractive
secure and and and and basically welfare
state world in the future so the
sustainable pathway just 10 years ago we
could not say that there was not enough
scientific evidence to say that the
sustainable path is the winning path but
today we can today we have the scalable
solutions to show that renewable energy
healthy and sustainable food all forms
of circular processes for material flows
can give better economies and better
outcomes on security health and
economies I think that's what
politicians need to understand that you
know the writing is on the wall on risk
but there's also a risk of losing the
race if you want to be a modern state in
the future and and modern communities or
wherever scale you are at and I think
that's that's a combination that again
we we need to come across even better
that we are using today great answer I
like the uh we're approaching
unmanageable risks that will get a lot
of attention so I think you want to add
anything or should I get another
question maybe I can just add on my on
The Limited context of cor reefs as we
are talking also to governments to get
the permits to build these um it really
depends also on the context but now in
the Philippines for example we saw um
great enthusiasm also for this um kind
of solution and others as well they
really and now protecting their marine
ecosystems and trying to and also other
countries like the Le and we're talking
to so there is interest and enthusiasm
to do something um sometimes it's hard
with financing and these kind of things
and bureaucracies but but there's a
recognition now where maybe 10 years ago
they would have just looked at you and
laughed yeah and they also do more
Marine protected areas for example and
and no take areas which is really
important for cories and other
ecosystems so this is a good development
we see good sign it's we call it a weak
signal that these are sting starting to
give us indicators of where things are
heading which is critical actually you
yeah I wanted to say something in that
sense we can also learn from other areas
I think one of the things that you see
in the work that has been done
scientific work in on climate
sustainability um it's very
observational right and we observe uh
nature and when you look at what she's
doing is an intervention and when we
want to develop new medical technology
there needs to be a clinical trial and I
think the politicians need to think more
along the lines in how we fund
interventions as well right in climate
let's say or something like that not not
just like stop things or you know there
needs to be interventions and there
needs to be an effect and so I think CES
are great right because you make an
intervention and then they should come
back and you can think about what does
it take to actually for them to come
back and maybe there's other examples
where you could do on a larger scale in
some of the other you know uh
sustainable goals that um that where can
we think about interventions and we
could show that this works right
something like that rather than just
observational I like that it's
intriguing the the experiment of the the
clinical trial the test a few hands went
up um we've got the microphone here and
when you do if you wouldn't mind
standing just so that those online can
also see you and we can see you because
we have lights so put your hands up
again who wants to ask come on okay here
let start in the back right there right
there just goad and stand up and if you
don't mind that helps a lot
thanks hi thank you for your for your
talk uh I was wondering you were talking
about interventions do you also mean
like climate
engineering it yeah so I think is
exactly that point right so finding more
examples of um you know engineering or
technology or anything you do that is an
intervention it can be a political
intervention but something that we get
tested in a trial and then you see like
have a control group and you have a
group that uh you you you don't treat in
that sense right and then you can look
really at the difference whether it it's
scientifically sound and I think things
like that find more such examples where
you can do such tests right so if you
have climb Works taking CO2 out of the
atmosphere uh can you show on a local
level that there's a difference right if
you if you do that you know rather than
you know just say like okay that's a
good thing to do we should do more of
that any other
responses there's another question right
here someone had their hand up right go
ahead and then right behind you um yes
so I'm getting a bit desperate you know
so we see the increasing evidence of
things changing ever faster on the other
hand humankind seems to be very good in
distracting itself with starting other
Wars and wars and Wars instead of
working together in solving these huge
issues we have I have been working on
solar energy so I see that we have the
solutions I see the exponential growth
which gives a lot of Hope but still
probably too slow to stay within the
safe zone so I'm wondering and the other
thing I think you mentioned it you know
probably all of us here live wealthy
enough live secure enough so that we
have the Mind space to keep each
ourselves busy with the things but the
majority of the people on this planet do
not have this possibility they need all
their head space to to stay alive b day
by day keep food food by day by day so
so what's the question how do we how do
we go on from there as scientists but
also as members of society
mhm
okay yeah I I can take I mean you're
absolutely right and and U you know
we've even published quite recently uh
and working on on the whole concept on
on approaching the risk of a poly crisis
and the poly crisis is academically
defined as when you have parallel Global
systemic crisis occurring simultaneously
and reinforcing each other so when you
have an economy and inflation you have a
war in Ukraine impacting on gas and
thereby fertilizers causing food
insecurity in the Horn of Africa plus
climate change causing water scarcity
and further reinforcing droughts and and
then Plus on top of that distrust in the
governance systems when these reinforce
each other you you come closer to a risk
of of not only unmanageable risks in the
your system but also unmanageable
outcomes and you get basically uh a halt
in in our Pathways towards a safe
landing on for example the energy
transition so you're absolutely right
there's a lot of turbulence that the
question is how to handle that and what
we're exploring increasingly is to find
you know radical alternative exponential
Pathways and and one of them could be
and we've actually experimented it uh to
some in in in one sector I'll give that
example which is by identifying Keystone
actors in different sectors so not not
bother about the way we've been dealing
with sustainability is for 50 years
namely that this is something that
should be done in consensus all
countries in the world should agree
basically our task is always to build
awareness and fundamentally we're
waiting for people to be willing to pay
and willing to act sustainably as if
it's always a question of of being
informed and taking information and then
lifting yourself up to a point that I'm
now willing to sacrifice a certain step
to be sustainable we say this is this is
this is the path this is not a solution
the pathway is rather to say the global
cement industry or This Global
fertilizer industry or the global energy
industry or the global Fisher industry
is often just 5 to 10 companies
controlling the whole Global Market and
this is published in several papers the
Keystone actors that basically control
the whole value chain fishing all the
oceans there's only 13 companies in the
world that controls like 70% of the
entire value chain in the seafood
industry in the world I mean I'm talking
all the tuna all the Cod all the Hal all
the basic fish that we eat is controlled
by just a handful of companies we
published a paper on this and then
academically you're normally finished
with your work but we actually took
ourselves away from that comfort zone
and invited the CEOs of all these 13
companies to a meeting to start an
initiative to see could we change the
attitude in these big Keystone actors
and that has now turned into something
called the seafood business for ocean
stewardship with 10 of these 13 now
being together one of them went bankrupt
a Spanish company and Alaskan company
did not want to join and a Chinese would
not join either but it's quite
interesting this is an effort of trying
to tip the entire logic that the theory
is that can if you get the Keystone
actors to change could that change the
logic in the global market because you
cannot get to all the millions and you
don't want to get to the small scale
Fisher communities because they are
struggling with their everyday life but
you have to get or you could get to the
Keystone actors we've done the same same
thing with the heavy truck industry did
you know that there are only six
companies in Europe producing trucks
only six we invited all the CEOs to The
poam Institute all of them came and that
led to a declaration where they said
okay if the world needs to be off
internal combustion engines by 2050 we
will stop selling internal combustion
engine driven trucks 10 years before
because it takes us 10 years to design a
new platform for our trucks this is uh
Daimler Volvo SCA
Ford um I'm missing one or two uh yeah
you see my point yeah Friday evening
anyway so so the point is these are
Keystone actors and and the theory is
can these tip over these this large
enough minority tip over the logic in
the in majority I know that this is U
quite unconventional we're exploring it
increasing in different sectors but it's
it's one way to address your question
because I totally agree we we cannot
expect people are struggling with their
everyday life to suddenly be sustainable
you know we have to make it easy for
them and we have to have the you know
almost like go in a bit um like you're
doing when working with your bones you
know you have to just simply go in like
a really touch the exact point the
levers of of of delicate change that's
why by the way to close this is say that
we we also doing the same thing on
climate you have four big actors which
is the US the European Union China and
India if the four of them just the four
of them really start acting you've
solved 70% of the problem 70% four
actors you know fundamentally you get
Modi kingping Ursa felion and Biden to
just agree shut them in a room throw out
the key don't let them out until it's
done then you would start and and the
thing is that if they would agree on a
global price on carbon for example it
would spill over on everyone
I'm of the view that the best thing
that's happened the last 5 years is the
European Union seam the the carbon
border adjustment mechanism that the
European Union is now threatening to
have an import tax on carbon because the
carbon price in Europe is so high that's
European Industries is starting to feel
that they cannot compete on equal
grounds that that would organically
start making a global price on carbon
and all science show that that could tip
the scale very rapidly so I don't think
we should give up but I totally agree
with with your concern and and we don't
have the answer yet but we like to
explore that in in new ways of of of
doing research in this area thank youan
thank you for the question and thank you
for that I think it's really interesting
if you think of healthy ecosystems the
apex predators are critical it's it's
totally inspired from ecology this is
really keystone species yeah determine
the outcome in the whole the whole chain
chain yeah really so so that's uh that's
where it comes from yeah the Keystone
actor idea that's really intriguing very
intriguing go ahead hello thank you for
the enriching conversation and
opportunity and Chris brought up two
forces the local force and the global
force and I want to bring another forces
the policym and the bottom up action uh
how do you see this forces playing the
next year the next years let's say uh if
one you see is going to be greater than
other or is going to cost more more
effect and what human humans problems do
you see they both have in in common as
blockers to to get what where we want to
get so Josephine you've been doing with
your yeah I mean we do probably more the
bottom up um approach with our Solutions
um which I think is key to just also
bring some Innovations in and just also
do something new right and then raise
awareness and then we all also see that
some local partners are now starting to
do their own things which is great
because there's so much scale um to to
regenerate cor re and at the same time
for us it's also critical to have as I
mentioned Marine protected areas for
example so more the policy level to
protect these reefs because if if we
build something and it's still
overfished and polluted and not
protected it doesn't make any sense so
for us I think it's really the interplay
um of both
levels if I may add to that I I think
you know most of the things are bottom
up that we experience there's there's
not so much policy making it's not the
policy that makes us use gas or you know
burn fuel right it's that would only be
a stoppable thing you know you stop it
right and you know make laws against it
so I think most of initiatives are
bottom up and don't think about just the
people that bought them up but also the
companies and small companies and larger
companies they bought them up and I
think they're going to be much faster
than politics in in the end and that's a
b example you said you bring these five
CEOs together and then they just decide
oh you know let's do that 10 years
earlier because that would not work in
in politics so easily and there's also a
larger scale there 12 126 companies that
are working together Le by swissy for
example in Insurance risks right and and
they very much uh doing that all they
have all kinds of things that they
working
on on their own because it's also
economical so I think this is a very
important part the bottom up that they
shouldn't be stopped by politics that's
the important part right so that uh of
course that you have a a spirit that you
can still go on and medicine is the same
thing right so it's just you need to
make sure that you don't do things that
are unsafe and you know reducing the
risk but then you let the people develop
innovate and and and there there's so
many more people than politicians right
so I think you can be much more creative
if you do that so I'm strong believer in
bottomup
initiatives do you want to comment or go
another question we can go to next okay
there's a who who's on that side of the
room there's gentleman right here in the
third fourth row then we're going to go
to the back then we're going to come
over here to the gentleman's been very
patient on the right yes um hello I have
one uh question regarding um the law of
the or the upcoming law of the ESG and
csrd Reporting in Europe um so this
would be an incentive for many companies
to um drive forward the sustainable
transformation how optimistic does this
directive make you and where do you
actually see potential maybe to make it
more tangible in the European Union to
actually drive forward um sustainable
transformation since the ipcc reports
also didn't make politicians that much
comply with
them I can't answer the question I have
no idea what you know what what the law
is are coming so no so well I I can just
share with you that our assessment is
that um U you know companies have many
times if not even generally come one
step further than policymaking in
recognizing the need to act particularly
on climate they are quite frustrated
right now because U there's so many
reporting schemes not only um let's say
policy deter determined ones like the E
ESG framework in the European Union but
also
voluntary um schemes like for example
the science-based target initiative and
and different uh schemes that that
companies really want to perform on
because it gives them a little bit of a
Competitive Edge and they can attract
more um really talented employees the
next generation of uh of skills so it's
quite interesting that that
being kind of let's say active on
climate reporting has become one of the
measures if you want to be a successful
company and that's really positive it's
not in the in entire world but it's it's
actually coming quite fast both in the
US and European Union but there's a
frustration over the Myriad of different
reporting schemes I'm of the view though
that overall even that chaos is actually
quite positive it forces companies to
really to really report however the the
problem I see is that I I I encounter
more and more cosos that say look here
here we have our conventional quarterly
reporting to our um you know our
shareholders and this is what we do on
our profits and and kind of basically
our our triple our bottom lines and then
we have to do the ESG reporting as well
still over here and of course that will
never make us succeed we have to make
these entirely together to say that the
sustainability reporting should be
integrated with the economic reporting
and should determine the economic
reporting in a much more you know full
way so what I always try to tell C that
your ultimate uh indicator of success is
when you can prove that you're earning
more money thanks to your
decarbonization work that you can really
show that this is a winning pathway for
profits because that will make the
policy makers more reassured yeah this
is this is good politics so but still we
are a little bit in the old school type
of measurements we're kind of imposing
these reporting schemes and and
businesses don't really see the the
benefits yet but it will come I'm quite
sure about that actually so so we still
have some work to do there to kind of
really make this s make sense for the
companies and the boards in the
companies But ultimately I think it's
good we're on the right trajectory right
we're on the right TR we there's a
question right in the back what's go
ahead do you want to say okay go ahead
go ah ask hi um um now um we basically
talk about about um the Regeneration
from social um from like
um sorry scientific way and I more
interested in um sociological
perspective because we have to like made
the balance between like natural science
and social sciences so from my
perspective view I have two questions
the first is first question is big and
there's um important term in sociology
which means um um historical conjuncture
uh it means that abunt uh change instead
of um accumulation that is very slow and
could you make like both assumption or
some prediction of uh like in the last
few years or 10 years let's say uh if if
they're about to like historical change
about to happen that's my first question
okay you get one question okay so there
there's your question there that's a
good one actually just because we'll
pause with that one because I think
that's actually a really fascinating one
the historical conjunction do we feel
like we're coming to a conjunction point
right what do you guys think I'm G to
start with Josephine yeah maybe I think
so from our point of view with cor ree
for example if it's likely that we see
that um um extinct in the already the
next decades right and now it looks very
bad you can see with the bleaching
events you can see with your own eyes
how it looks like so I feel like and
that's sad but maybe once like these
kind of thresholds are are
passed I feel like then hopefully
there's an Awakening um but you already
see now more and more talk about if
there are bleaching EVS in Australia for
example or Florida that's happening more
so I feel like because it's only a
matter of time since we are at these
kind of tipping points now um I think
there will be historic change if we want
to kind of yeah the social awareness is
actually Rising I think that's what any
other Johan what do you think yeah I
think if if you look at it at at a
global scale I think the answer is no
we've not reached we've not crossed a
social Tipping Point we're not at a kind
of a social transformation truly but I
think we're seeing more and
more um you know Pockets regions that
are really showing uh clear sign of
let's say irreversible social change
towards shifting much more in terms of
resource efficiency and U and particular
on climate transition and you certainly
see it in certain economic sectors I
mean for example Electric Mobility is is
definitely an industry that has totally
shifted I mean if you look at Germany
and what's happening with um the car
industry it's um it's it's it's beyond
the point of no return to move away from
the internal combustion engine I mean
we're we're in the beginning of the end
of the diesel and gasoline driven
mobility in Europe for example I mean
that's that's clear that is a in my view
that's a that's an it's an engineering
uh feat but it's a social transition
it's it's a conjuncture definitely but I
don't I don't personally I don't feel
that we're we're not yet there when it
comes to the entire world is not on
board I think comes back to the question
earlier here on on on the inequities in
the world and how the vast majority are
still struggling just to make their
their kind of daily life um Advanced I
think it's a really great question
that's
why not move now there's no more point
of return didn't you see that did I
totally misunderstand you what I what I
said is that cop this cop meeting ISS
and and well I would say that many of us
in the climate science Community
assessed that this is the last chance we
have to start bending the curve on
fossil fuel emissions so it's not it's
not the end of the world but the ipcc
shows clearly that if we do not bend the
global curve of emissions by 2025 we
have no chance of of of staying within
the global carbon budget that can hold
the 1.5° C limit so if we want to have a
chance we need to do something now 2023
to really start bending the curve and
and the challenge is that we're making
huge progress on renewable energy in the
world but so far it's only meeting
growing demand it's not changing the
trajectory on oil coal and gas that's
the problem we have to start really
bending that so that's what I said cop
28 in my view must be the the the
mitigation cop and can you imagine 28
climate meetings have so far not been
really about mitigation meaning phasing
out fossil fuels it's been about
fighting over brackets and commas it's
been about adaptation and finance and
loss and damage and all the other issues
really important issues but we have to
come to a point where we start have
incredible Pathways to phase out oil
coal and gas and and that's what I meant
with the cop
28 thank you that I'm going to come back
to rethinking
regeneration right I'm going to bring it
bring it back here for a minute going to
bring it back to the center of the table
uh I say it with a smile because you
know it is very very serious what we're
talking about here because you mentioned
before this is about the Regeneration of
our planet and now it it her capacity to
regenerate to allow this to us Homo
sapiens to have a and all the living
other beings to have a um a safe
operating system so I'm not making light
of this it's just I'm want to bring it
back to Regeneration for a moment um
William
Gibson has says you know the future's
already here just unevenly
distributed right and and I I like that
because that means there are places in
the world we can look to as exemplars to
amplify the positive say ah there there
that's where we need to look so in each
of your in each of your domains your
worlds where would you where do you Look
To Be Inspired or to say hey this is
something that's really interesting to
to share with us that you say there's a
direction for the
future and and any of you so who wants
to
go all right they're all looking at your
you want Josephine all right you got it
I can um yeah for us I think it's really
the local communities and the NOS we
find as well so to see on the ground how
people already suffer from the loss of
cor reefs and then I mean we have one
approach to restore but there as I said
Marine protected areas there are other
Fisheries like fishermen who already
understand that they can't fish
everything but they fish more
sustainable because they realize that it
has an impact on on their livelihoods as
well then they are more fish and I think
to see these uh different approaches and
mindsets locally and how we can uh
combine these approaches with us um
there are also great other startups for
example who who uh PL climate resilient
corals on health wees or on structures
like we do and I think that's very
inspiring to see these different
approaches and how to bring them
together to boost the resilience of this
ecosystem that's cool so the local the
locals you work with inspire you yeah
that's great Ralph what about you yeah
it's I had a chance to think about a
little bit it's actually not so easy
know that she started was really good um
no I think the I I find it fascinating
to look sometimes also very small uh
these days we can go really detailed and
it used to be that we could only look at
one small little thing and then you know
there's so many small things many atoms
right and you could not have a a further
inside but today we have so much data
available that we can store all of this
information and learn from these kinds
of things and so I mean like there was
also a little bit the social part that
you mentioned um that uh I think we had
the Tipping Point because everybody is
on has a social media type of approaches
data is used um positively or negatively
so we have this wealth of data that I'm
fascinated by but we have to make good
use of it and not uh produce only fake
uh news right in that sense so I think
this is something that I'm very
interested how can we use all of that
data to bring messages across that will
influence people because they look at it
every day we're looking at it we are
consuming this data that is produced and
I find it very fascinating how how then
even the world is coming together is not
you go to a remote place they still have
the same data that they actually uh draw
their conclusions on and how do we make
that available to the people right in in
a good way also scientists now right in
in a responsible way so I'm I'm
fascinated about that thought how we can
use this information on the very local
level on an atomistic level and and
maybe get information out for you that
helps understanding what happens and how
we do interventions that's cool thank
you for
that yeah so I I told a few examples of
that when it comes to Electric Mobility
and when it comes to renewable energy so
let me take a another example that I
find really inspiring and I take it
deliberately because it it's worth
mentioning that I I I started by sharing
that six of the nine Planet boundaries
are outside of the safe space and we
know that the energy transition is one
of the pathways to bring us back but the
most important one is actually the food
system transition because that would
bring us back on freshw use on
biodiversity loss on pollution of marine
systems from nitrogen phosphorus
overloading the loss of biodiversity
land system change and I think one of
the most exciting ing developments we
see among small scale Farmers
particularly in in in in South America
but also parts of southern Africa is is
the transition away from plowing to
different forms of minimum tillage
systems and this is defined as
conservation agriculture uh there are
many scholars that today show that one
of the biggest mistakes we did in in the
Agricultural Revolution was to start
plowing because plowing means we turn
the soil and it burns organic carbon it
destroys a large parts of the biology in
the in the root Zone layer in the soils
it leads to more erosion and land
degradation and it loses soil water hole
in capacity but there's so many
implements today even pulled by oxen
where you simply just open up the soil
and you can plant exactly like Precision
farming for small scale farmers and you
maintain soils as close as possible to
Nature and you build organic carbon you
have much more productive soils and this
has led to an agricultural revolution in
parts of of Latin America as we speak
actually we never talk about this and
it's coming more and more in countries
like Zimbabwe Kenya Bina Faso nir it's
quite interesting Zambia so I think
that's one of the promising Pathways
because it's a it's building more
resilient it's more regenerative but
it's also a carbon sequestration
strategy so you know there are these um
almost
silent large system changes occurring
bottom up uh that we they're just
occurring there without us even
recognizing them fully it's a really
fantastic example Yan with the
importance of soil or soil health and
the food that we eat and where it comes
from and that's actually the
conversation we're be having here
tomorrow evening okay yeah so thank you
for that transition I I do appreciate
that that's perfect not not planned at
all no not at all but I I'll pay you
afterward that's great thank you oh good
thanks yeah thank you so I do want to
thank our panel this evening for being
here and for really taking us on an
amazing Journey from the planet all the
way down to the cell and in between it's
really been fantastic so Johan Josephine
and um Ralph thank you let's give him a
nice of
Applause and I and i' wouldd like to
thank all of you very very much for
choosing to be here this evening on
Friday evening those of you here in the
room and those of you online it's been
really great to have you here excellent
really excellent questions extremely
thoughtful group I know Johan's got a
bolt off but we're going to be here for
a few more minutes now tomorrow evening
I did mention rethinking Urban
agriculture will be right here at at
18:15 at 6:15 an earlier slot with Iris
haror Marcel gra and Ana stegle uh we'll
be talking about some of the things
which you've just mentioned right there
at the very end so thank you very much
and we will see you tomorrow I hope all
right awesome thank you very
much